so we're told that minlee has five more
dollars than james midley has 33 dollars
how much does james have
so let's let's use some letters to
represent the amount of money min lee
has and the amount of money james has so
let's say that m
is the is represents the amount of money
that min lee has
and j represents the amount that james
has
so we're told that mintley has five more
dollars than james so min lee's money or
the amount of money min lee has is going
to be equal to the amount of money james
has
plus five
so plus
plus
five start with the amount james has add
five you have min lees min lee has five
more dollars than james
now they tell us min lee has 33 dollars
so let me write this down so we know
that m
m is equal to so this this sentence
right here tells us
this right here tells us that m
is equal to 33 dollars
so instead of an m here we could say
well 33 dollars is equal to
is equal to the amount of money james
has
plus
plus five and so now we just need to
think about how much money does james
have and i encourage you to pause the
video and think about it on your own
well one way to visualize this is maybe
on a number line so let me draw a number
line right over here
and
let's say this is zero
this is the amount that min lee has
right up here
so min lee has 33 dollars that
represents that point right over here
and j
is the amount that james has so let's
say that this is j right over here and
we know that if we add 5 to j if you
take j add 5 you get to 33. so you start
at j if you add 5
you get
you get to 33. well how can i go to 33
to how can i start with m or how can i
start with the amount min lee has and
then end up with the amount james has
well i could just go the other way
around i could start with m and i could
subtract five i could subtract five so
we could say that 33 which is m the
amount of money min lee has
minus five
minus five is equal to the amount of
money that james has
so how much money does james have well
33 minus 5 is going to be 28.
so we can say that james
james
has 28 is equal to j or james has 28
dollars so this right over here is 28
and you see that 28
plus 5 is 33. 33 is 5 more than 28 so
this all works out now let's think about
this next question
jessica's house is five times as far
from school as paulette's house
jessica's house is 15 miles from school
how far is paulette's house from the
school
so just like we did let's just look at
each of these sentences and see what
they're telling us and i encourage you
to define use some letters to represent
the distance jessica's house from school
and paulette's house from school and try
to figure this out on your own pause the
video right now and try to figure out on
your own
so you could imagine j might be a good
letter for jessica's the distance from
jessica's house to school and let's say
that p
will use for paulette's house from
school
so we're told that however far
paulette's house is from school you take
five times that to see how far jessica's
house is from school
so we could write that
p which is how far paulette's house is
from school
times five
times five
times 5 is equal to how far jessica's
house is from school jessica's house is
five times as far from school as
paulette's house p is paulette's house
is distance from school j is jessica's
house's distance from school
they then tell us that jessica's house
is 15 miles from school
so that they're essentially telling us
this sentence right over here they're
telling us that j is equal to 15.
j
is equal to 15. so we can rewrite this
as
the distance paulette's house is from
school times five which we know to be
jessica's distance from school or
jessica's house is distance from school
which we now know to be 15
is going to be equal to
15.
so what would p be
some number times 5 is going to be equal
to 15. some number of miles times 5 is
equal to 15 miles well you might already
be able to think about this in your head
but we could also visualize it
so let's draw a number line again
let's draw a number line again
and if you start with that number p so
let's this is paulette's distance from
school so p and you multiply it by 5.
so that's times 1 times 2
times 3 times 4 times 5. so notice this
is p this distance is p right over here
this is another p
right over here this is another p
right over here that's another p right
over there and another p
right over there or another way of
thinking about it this whole distance
right over here is going to be p plus p
plus p plus p plus p
or
p
times five
p
times five and that's equal to how far
jessica is from school or jessica's
house is from school so this right over
here is equal to 15 which is the same
thing which is the same thing as j
so how would you figure it out well if 5
times p is equal to 15 if i want to
figure out what p is i could just divide
15 into five equal groups so we could
say that p
p
is equal to 15
is equal to 15 divided into five equal
groups if you take 15 miles and divide
it into five equal groups that's going
to you're going to end up with p so what
is this
well we get p 15 divided by 3 is sorry
15 divided by 5 is 3.
so paulette paulette lives 3 miles from
school and you see that if this is a
three another three another three plus
another three and another three three
times five is fifteen jessica's house
which is 15 miles from school is five
times as far from school as paul's house
which is three miles from school so it
all makes sense